[Music]
foreign hello there you are watching The
Press preview a first look then at what
is on the front pages time to see what
is making the headlines with the
political editor of the guardian
papakura and the political editor of the
son Harry Cole welcome to both of you
so let's take a look at the front pages
Then Shall We The Guardian leads on that
statement from Vladimir Putin earlier
where he claimed that his enemies wanted
Russia to choke in bloody civil Strife
the head of the Wagner militia has
denied trying to overthrow the Russian
government that's on the front of the
financial times same story there is some
safety advice for Afghani precaution on
the front page of the star best stay
away from open windows
in other news a call for Bank branches
to retain their presence on the High
Street makes the top story for the
express the Metro leading on the inquest
into the death of Nicola bully which
heard that she drowned after falling
into a river
we're reminded by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us
we're joined then by paper career and
Harry Cole
um and Pippa we've heard haven't we from
both pragosian and Putin today
um you know possibly different stories
but you know can Putin you know regain
his hard man image do you think after
the extraordinary events of this weekend
I think it's going to be very hard for
him I mean what has happened in Russia
um we're still trying to you know
exactly what's happened we're still
trying to find out and um isn't entirely
clear although we have had a bit more
information that you say Anna
um in the form of an 11-minute telegram
address from pagosian uh earlier on and
then of course Vladimir Putin's really
quite angry television statement
um to the Russian people and what seems
to have happened and it's obviously
we're you know analysts are much more
expert than Harry or I are pouring over
all of this but what seems to have
happened is that
um a fairly sort of um I wouldn't quite
say standard but but a dispute between
two senior figures in
um in the the Russian Moscow regime
um the the defense minister and
obviously the head of Wagner
um have uh their their conflict which I
think in in other times might have been
resolved with a judgment from Putin on
which side he fell down he fell on um
and obviously the dispute was based
around Wagner and pragosian's feeling
that the defense minister and the
defense Ministry Russian army hadn't um
hadn't prosecuted the invasion of
Ukraine in the way that it should have
done
um and uh that didn't happen Putin
didn't come down with a judgment and so
uh Wagner marched on Moscow with these
extraordinary uh images and
extraordinary circumstances that we saw
over the weekend which have I think
irrevocably rocked Putin's position and
given the ongoing uncertainty made it
very difficult
um for the rest of us let alone you know
those in those in Russia to see exactly
how this is going to play out and how
this power play is going to is going to
culminate
yes and the financial times picking up
and the pregosian statement this evening
rather than the Putin one
um with the denial that he tried to oust
Putin uh in his 11 minute voice
recording he said his goal was to
protest against a recent decision to
disband Wagner and to demonstrate the
weakness of Russia's domestic defenses
we didn't have the goal of toppling the
existing regime from Putin's point of
view though his statement is video
statement denied said I emphasized from
the very beginning of the events all the
necessary decisions were immediately
taken to neutralize the threat that had
Arisen to protect the Constitutional
order the life and security of our
citizens which seems so strange when the
Wagner group got so far Harry what you
know what's your thoughts of of what
happened over the weekend and what were
to make of it
the first hour we asked people said you
know carry out this with you know most
western intelligence agencies are still
grappling with what's exactly happened
um at the weekend we don't know this is
obviously a very fluid situation and a
live moving situation still all this
talk of a deal done um you know
obviously because was able to flee but
in his statements now Putin appears to
have revoked any suggestion that you
know he's off the hook for this
um it took um Trotsky 14 years of
looking over his shoulder before the ice
pick finally came all the way in Mexico
um Bella Russia is not that far from uh
from from Moscow so I'm not Imagining
the iron former Now parking the boss is
sleeping too easily at the moment uh and
uh having watched that statement from
Putin that's not a man that looks like
he's gonna back down one thing I would
say is though do not underestimate the
that Putin it's clear that the the
bargain of column as it was advancing up
towards the capital was not being joined
in this in in the way that it was it
needed to be if this was going to be a
successful purchase for all this idea
that now it wasn't it wasn't a coup
that's not what the guy was saying at
the time he was saying in fact the exact
opposite he made some pretty bellicose
direct threats to the regime to very
senior figures in it and what's clear is
that it despises his FSB the gru whoever
did not join with Vagner in fact the
Russian military hate that though
because they've embarrassed them along
the way on many occasions over the last
few years so they were kind of caught
with their trousers down halfway to the
capital and decided to run away so
um I would um I would I wouldn't be
sleeping too easy if I was exiled in
Bella Russia tonight well absolutely
that's the front page of the star isn't
it uh best stay away from open Windows
um you know there is a ruthlessness
certainty uh that President Putin has
shown anybody who he deems to have
committed treason against the nation you
know deal or no deal we'll see what
happens
um you know where is precaution now is
he in mince because there are some
reports what happens to his you know his
Wagner foot soldiers will they take up
the offer of merging with the uh with
the Russian Ministry of defense will
they go home to their families will they
go to Belarus
um you know have they lost the the best
fighting force that Russia is so far you
know presented itself with Pippa
well percussion in his uh remarks
earlier seemed to suggest that his
troops would not sign contracts uh with
the Russian Ministry of Defense now as
far as I can make out he is he remains
popular with the Wagner troops and um
and as it has a sort of a strong
personal following so without him on the
scene or without his Blessing it's
unlikely that that substantial numbers
of Wagner troops will will sign up to
the ministry of Defense not least
because
um it's run by Sergey shoigu who who of
course was is the individual who um who
most has most upset
um pagosjin and the and the Wagner group
for his handling of the Ukraine conflict
so um he seemed to be suggesting
precaution this is that um the vaginal
troops might actually come to Belarus
with him and Putin also similarly in his
address suggested that that might be an
option for them there's some suggestion
that lukashenko the president Alexander
the president of Belarus might allow the
vagina group to train
um on on their territory that obviously
then opens up the prospect of
um the conflict moving into Ukraine from
the north of Ukraine directly from
Belarus which is obviously going to be
something on the ground in Ukraine which
zelenski and his
um his generals will be will be watching
very closely
um it is all just shredded in a great
deal of uncertainty but you know as as
we've seen as Harry says anybody that
that sort of challenges Putin directly
even those including who were once seen
as as you know a real sort of loyal
supporter a better watch I I mean we saw
last September prominent Russian oil
um oligarch ending up falling out
falling out of the sixth floor of a a
Russian a Russian Hospital Moscow
hospital and he was just the latest in
the series of uh senior Russian
individuals who have in some way or
other angered or stood up to the Putin
regime reaching a similar fate so you
know that's the front page of the star
so as we've already said I don't think
precaution is going to be sleeping very
well in his bed tonight in Minsk or
wherever else he actually is
picking up on you know what what
Russia's enemies wanted the organizers
of the Rebellion uh having betrayed
their country their people betrayed
those who were drawn into the crime
pushed them pushed them to death Under
Fire to shoot at their own he called it
fracticide that the enemies of Russia
wanted uh in Kiev the neonats is in Kiev
and their Western patrons and all sorts
of national traitors I mean the words of
Putin uh this evening
um but indeed yes I mean Ukraine would
have you know rubbed its hands with Glee
at this at this activity it's all these
extra and incidental elements that have
made the war so extraordinary in recent
months the kakovka dam
um for one
um the raids into Belgard by the free
Russia troops and now this whatever it
was this Rebellion Harry
um it didn't go on long enough really
for for Ukraine to feel the benefit on
the front line of of this action yeah I
think one thing that was quite clear was
that the troops stationed on the front
were not diverted back to the motherland
to try and fight this it was as you say
over too quickly but I mean as a loss of
face reputation this cannot be played
down I think the West has sort of agreed
this joint line that it shows real
cracks but have stopped short of saying
it's going to be it's going to be fatal
um if anything it could actually have
the opposite effect of forcing an
already fairly ruthless uh leader
um to crack down even further on his
country I have to say if you're a
Russian citizen who hasn't got a
watching television over the last few
months and years has been told
everything's going brilliantly
um so then suddenly see your your leader
on televisions without blood curdling
series of statements the one on Saturday
morning and the one tonight
um you know it's very hard to contain
the idea that everything's going
tickety-boo when you have to go on
television and say actually you know
blood was being spilled six planes were
being shot down there was fracture side
going on in the country so I I wonder
how you know as a sort of PR uh moment
for the Putin regime whether that's
going to be the real damage that people
aren't necessarily going to believe a
single word he's saying anymore and uh
just as I spoke in fact I see a um a
drop on the Reuters news agency uh
zielinski saying we are making advances
in all sectors it is a happy day
um I don't know any more context than
that but uh but we'll certainly see um
we know that he visited uh the front
line as well himself uh today so um you
know this this story continues obviously
let's move on though if we can to the
Stephen Lawrence case
um you know clearly of great distress
once again to to Steven's family Pippa
the idea that yet again Justice was not
served in this case
yeah it's very sad this story isn't it I
mean just your heart just breaks for
um for Neville and Doreen Lawrence
Stevens parents who after all these
years 30 years are still having to go
through the turmoil of feeling that
Justice hasn't been done for their son
and that
um they can't even be at peace
um the the
um the this was an official
investigation
um uh has concluded the Scotland Yard
had information that could and should
have been handed into to the inquiry
into Lawrence's murder of a field to
disclose it
um and you know the met this obviously
comes after The Met
um it emerges the sixth suspect in his
killing was identified
um and Stephen Lawrence's father and
Dwayne Brooks who had obviously was
their
um uh in that street in Nelson when he
was attacked and murdered had called for
the Met to reopen the investigation so
this was um an individual called Matthew
white he he died in 2021 and the police
had twice looked into him
um but seemed to slip through their
fingers
um and it's obviously once again raises
huge questions about
um the original met inquiry
um it concerns also about what the Met
told the MacPherson inquiry which was
the the inquiry that obviously took
place
um in the in the uh the years following
the the Lawrence case and concluded that
the Met was institutionally racist and
actually led to some really quite
profound changes in in British policing
in general not just in the mid
um as a result of the McPherson report
but there's questions that even that met
maybe hadn't been completely straight
with what they knew and didn't know when
it came to um dealing with McPherson so
you know I just I just feel really sad
about it for the family's perspective
that this is this is not yet a bit laid
to rest um that there are obviously
other individuals who were
who were involved in this that they
haven't yet been brought to Justice
um and still many many unanswered
questions for the for the Lawrence
Family and many questions that they met
itself still has to answer on this as
well